I'm Aaron Donald, here with Bleacher Report, to build my all-time Super Bowl team.
I gotta go Brady.
He won six Super Bowls, so you know he gonna find a way to win.
For a running back...
Barry Sanders.
He make you miss, make you look silly.
I seen a lot of crazy highlights of him.
Ahh...he's consistent.
You know he gonna be the same, he gonna dominate every single time, similar, same way.
DB...
that's Prime Time.
It was either Prime Time or Ed Reed for me.
Returning too, both of them, but, ya know, Prime Time did some stuff.
And, linebacker...
he's a freak.
He's a freak. He do it all, so...
we gonna—we lockin' it in.
So, I put Tom Brady at quarterback
obviously cuz he won six Super Bowls,
so you know he's gonna find a way to win. He's consistent.
Barry Sanders, like...
he's one of my favorite running backs ever.
Ya know, if you ever seen him play...
some of the things he can do, you know he gonna, he gonna make them big plays
when you need it in the run game.
Jerry Rice, he's consistently dominated, you know, for years when he played.
Deion Sanders...
Prime Time, he return, he can run the ball, do a lot of different things,
and if he catch the ball to get a pick-six, you know he gonna score.
And Lawrence Taylor, you know, one of the best defensive players to ever do it,
get after the quarterback and do it all, so that,
that's my pick right there.
All these players right here consistently did it when they, when they played.
Consistently did it year in and year out, ya know,
so I'm all into consistent football play,
and I think that them guys is who it is.
Just here with Snickers promotin' a, you know, Super Bowl commercial.
Um, everybody know all the ads they do, ya know.
If you're outta sorts, eat a Snickers.
When the world outta sorts, let's feed the world a Snickers, and,
and, and make the world better, so
just part of a fun commercial, funny commercial,
and happy to be here with Snickers.